BUT 6'5" BARKOV
AN
THAT'S BEEN CONTAGIOUS FOR THE
WHOLD I HAVE TO THINK THE FLORI
PANTHERS HAVE TO GET TO THE
INSIDE MORE THAN THEY DID IN
ORLOONT.
MAKING SURE YOU GET THE REBOUNDS
IF THEY'RE THERE.
BEAUTIFUL.
>> HAS OSHIEIEHE PENALTY AFTER
WHISTLE.
NO CALLS BEING MADE..
>> AND BENNETT FORCED IT AROUND.
A BOUNCER FROM.
CARLSON, OVECHKIN, SCORES!FF THE
FROM AN IMPOSSIBLE ANGLE MOVES
GETS IT SEALED.
HE SCORES.
THE RESPONSE IS IMMEDIATE FROM
FLORE CAP PLAYERS TEAMMATES TO .
TAPPED ON FOR SHERRYY NICK
LUNDELL A PERFECT GIVE AND GO B.
VERHAEGHE SCORES.
HE JUS
THEY BEAT THE NEUTRAL ZONEAINSTN
CAPITALS IN GAME NUMBER ONE.R TE
THIRD PERIOD.
>> I MEAN, THERE'S A NUMBER OF
REASONS FOR THAT, I'M SURE
AND STAYS ON SIDE BY HUBERDEAU .